allez le shérif aux pattes ancienne
scène quoi que tu fais partie je n'aime
pas on y va sébastien chabal
[Applaudissements]
aïe sont pas fichés holding j'aime
j'aime pas on n'avait pas de choses à
faire mais on va parler juste de pascal
le grand frère parce qu'on déterre du
mortard ya x men le commencement est
vrai très gros film pascal le grand
frère
j'aime j'aime pas j'aime à agathe un
gars tu aimes bien et ça n'avait fait
tout cela gâte maxime
alors on va voir un extrait hier dans
l'émission dont on a rencontré anaïs une
adolescente de saison elle est très
rebelle notamment envers sa mère elle
n'hésite pas à lui dire qu'elle a une
mauvaise haleine par exemple ou regarder
et j vous n'avez pas du tout aimé les
luttes auront dire tu pue de la gueule
rires tata me dit battu pinailleuse elle
sait que j'ai eu des problèmes d'estomac
elle pense pourvoir matin avec sa femme
ce sont les chevaux de selle donc
s'attacher à pau alors j'ai essayé hier
c'était donc un des extraits vous aimez
vous dites ça parce que parce qu'elle
est là vous n'aimez pas valérie mais non
mais j'adore parce qu elle je lui ai
déjà dit à plusieurs reprises c'est que
mouassa m'empresse en fait je suis très
angoissé quand je le regarde donc je me
dis ça me gêne donc j'ai envie de zapper
pour pour passer à autre chose et
revenir quand ça sera bien il y en avait
un autre la table gilles verdez parce
que c'est surtout ça je voulais juste
voir si vous aimez le cinéma garder vos
pancartes
vous n'avez pas du tout aimé l'émission
d'hier vous vouliez même en ont parlé à
pascal bien sûr pascal l'a déjà que la
france attend maintenant vos excuses
c'est une catastrophe
ce n'était pas le grand frère c'était
pascal le grand père il s'est rien passé
il y avait des ralentis interminables et
des plantes vous en permanence au début
vous avez pris le melon par les bots
c'est pas lui qui te salue kimon plans
ralentis six mois j'étais film au
ralenti depuis été en arrêt est en arrêt
sur le fond depuis depuis longtemps
hôtel en vieux temps aaron
[Applaudissements]
en fait tu es prétend sur cette coiffe
et qu'est ce qui se passe c'est toi qui
est mou c'était tellement mauvais ton
truc qu'on aurait dit un mauvais de leur
mode entre alors en bagarre avec serait
pascal hop tu devais pas parce que il ya
moi je t'ai trouvé drôle tu t'es moquer
d'anaïs qu'être passion pour les white
s'est trouvé très drôle
vous avez veulent pousser la
chansonnette perdu j'ai trouvé drôle
vigiles vous n'avez pas trouvé l'épisode
bout mais voulait pas d'humour mais bien
pascal quand même non oui oui oui on a
pas du goût des autres chaînes c'est sa
10e ses fans de ces mecs là franchement
sans classe explique là quand tu vas
voir ta piaule jazzer toi tu es une
femme oublie moi c'est quoi la même
d'écrire une chanson je cite cette mini
krach ça va sur un plaisir de chanter sa
patte sur un accent anglais
oui mais oui mais quoi m'accuse
[Applaudissements]
alors nouvelle carrière pour moi j'ai eu
c'est vrai alors qu'il reste à répondre
pourquoi tu comment tu l'as trouvé tout
l'épisode d'hier dit la vérité mais bon
elle était bien on a une grosse
concurrence
banal comme le foot en face ils ont fait
4 millions et puis moi on n'est pas trop
mauvais fait quatre ans de 500 à 1000
milles serval ça pas mal ce coup c'est
voilà c'est ça passe c'est à dire voilà
on dit la vérité cependant je ne fais
pas ouf mais ça passe voilà oui et vous
contentez tournez-vous participé au
montage aussi que c'est un peu ce que la
voir on se calme parce que la voix off
là elle est complètement justement là
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
alors par exemple à voir l'épisode
d'hier l'épisode était mou il a même
plus de sport moi j'adorais quand on
tapait sur la glace comme sa démission
en vrai will et hier c'est un coup de
gueule contre l'émission dim et oui
c'est s était soporifique quoi alors moi
je peux vous dire un truc pascal mais
dit la vérité
moi j'adore l'émission merci mais c'est
vrai que je trouve que ça manquait un
peu de calme et oui je trouve que depuis
que l'émission est arrivée sur ces 8 je
ne sais pas si c'est la chaîne qui fait
des conneries au blocage
c'est très possible années n'ont plus dé
geely
on n'est pas des génies on va dire on
fait beaucoup de conneries aussi je fais
partie de la chaîne je me mets dedans et
je sais pas je trouve que ça s'est un
petit peu
il disait alors utilisé par rapport à ce
qu'ils avaient avant alors est ce que
c'est une demande de ses huit n'ont pas
du tout auparavant ont cassé des briques
ont cassé la glace
monsieur gilles verdez se plaignait
parce qu'on cassait trop de choses
maintenant on est dans la vraie vie
c'est ça la vraie vie c'est ça et
monsieur gillard est ça ne lui plaît pas
mais il ne dit rien qui lui place une
vraie vie c'est pas du tir à la corde et
de traction comme à bouger je vais te
souhaite sortir construit lorsqu'il a
regardé l'émission ballaro car gagner
deux fois je me souviens du foot deux
fois j'ai regardé la regarde et attend
que ça à faire regardez le me fait
l'émission pour venir qui se fait chier
que fatou je suis moi je suis fan de
pascal il le sait je trouve que
l'émission en tant que tel après son
passage à l'énergie d'où je pense qu'il
faudrait vraiment garder votre
personnage et faire un truc vraiment
différent hier mais effectivement je me
suis franchement je me suis un peu
ennuyé n'y avait pas les codes que
j'avais pu retrouver à laon le
producteur c'est julien voulait tourner
à une pépite comme bouge fort ce cas est
évidemment regardé le créneau mais c'est
un truc différent mais honnêtement pour
moi y'a plus de surprises alors leur
région voilà voilà
après pascal c'est une fille ou un
garçon une fille a une fille encore
moins moi je pense que mes fils rats qui
sera différent de celui ci et là vous
allez voir et te dis la vérité aussi je
pense cédé il ya des erreurs
les filles - ouais j'ai c'est vrai que
je trouve que c'est moins gênant avec
des garçons qu'avec biffi pascal canfin
je prends ensuite le prochain ce sera
encore des versions mais mes frères
cette fois ci très belle merde c'est en
tout cas voilà gilles tétanie ce que tu
as à dire tu dis la vérité